to be ready to go. All right, welcome to another Zoom call. We are recorded. This is 5, 9, 18.
Time is just flying. It's summer here now. The next week and then we start fall. And that's
Minnesota. But seriously, here's a slide. I don't know why I put that up there. Change your attitude
and change your life. Well, I put up there because attitude is important. And I for one,
10 to end up getting a bad attitude sometimes. So it's a good reminder for me. Maybe other people
have that same struggle. Maybe you're not just this overly positive, bubbly person all the time.
And it's easy to get discouraged. It's easy to get down. It's easy to look at all the struggles
that you're having in life and to be overcome by those sometimes and kind of get a
front of attitude. And it's just a nice reminder to purposefully change your attitude.
Personally, I'm a person that has to listen to motivational speakers, motivational
lectures on a regular basis. I don't know if it's some it's just my bent on life. I came from a
background where I wasn't always encouraged. But in fact, if I could remember, if you asked me,
what is the one thing you remember your mother telling you, it would be the phrase, you can't do that.
And just kind of like that, you can't do that. She told me about that about everything. So it
wasn't really encouraged in my life. When I was going to go to college to become a doctor,
which was the dream of my life when I was in high school. I ended up getting married right
out of high school and my dad strongly encouraged me not to continue college because it was about a waste
of money because I wasn't going to finish it. It's weird because I never did finish anything else
in my life. But of course, I was the eighth out of ninth children. So he didn't see all the seventh
that came before me, not finish college. I was the first one to graduate from college.
Though many of them started off in college, never ended up finishing. So there was a track record
in our family, but zero encouragement. So I need a lot of encouragement. I don't know if any of you
are in that same situation. So I like to listen to Tony Robbins and motivational speakers that I can
find. And the beautiful thing about YouTube these days is all you need to do is go on YouTube and
search motivational speakers or positivity for cancer or whatever you want to do. And you can come up,
you'll pull up a whole bunch of wonderful videos and TED Talks of people that make their living
and their giftedness is in helping us change our attitude and stay focused on positive things.
So I'd encourage you to do that if that is a little bit of your bent emotionally. I would
highly encourage you to do that because it can be very helpful to change your life. So we spoke a
few weeks ago about different issues in our life, including cancer or other diseases that are tied
to our attitudes that is important to help break that. So this is another piece to work on.
This is one of my favorite verses. Considered all Joey when you would coat your various trials,
knowing that the testing of your faith produces endurance. And that's how you can get through. This
is at least one of the verses that's helped me get through trials in my life, realizing that
there's no surprise to God. And he allows these trials in our life to shape us and mold us to the
image of his son and to make us stronger people and to give us a witness and a testimony. So that is
a beautiful thing. So if you could keep that focused, it's not about having a great attitude. So your
life is all perfect. It's about having a great attitude in that your state focused on what the
Lord's purpose is for you in the middle of your trials. And that's the key thing. It's not that God's
going to wipe them all away and make all your sadness become happiness, but he can take your
sadness and turn it to joy, which is independent of your circumstance. And that's the key point.
All right, sorry about my little soapbox there. Let's jump onto the questions. Here was a question,
a good question came in. In our cancer diet guideline notebook, it states that natural sweeters should
be used in place of sugar, but limited. How much is limited? Is it appropriate for one substitution
acceptable? Eat as a cup of sugar, use an acceptable substitution for the cup of sugar. Is that okay?
Still making cookies that way. What is considered too much? How about stevia, which is labeled
in an notebook as acceptable? Is that to be treated any different than the other natural sweeters?
Wonderful question. So usually this is gone over by the person who went over your three rig binder,
but I know it's like drinking from a fire hose on your second day here. Sometimes you don't hear
and it doesn't all get registered. You have to understand that even good natural sweeters like,
oh, can I drink? Can I eat all the raw honey that I want? Can I eat all the manuka honey that I want
because it's natural? Can I eat all the pure maple syrup that I want or coconut palm sugar? The
answers know you can't because still though these are natural sweeters, they're still going to break down
to glucose. So here's a picture. I just pulled off the internet of the glycemic index. That means
the rate at things break down into glucose. Well of course glucose breaks down into glucose.
It is glucose. Tamel sugar is sucrose. That is, you know, two sugar molecules together and they
break down, it breaks down into glucose very quickly. And then like the erythritol manital and
the sugar alcohols are down here at they have a very low glycemic index, but that doesn't necessarily
mean that they're healthy sugars to eat constantly. So is it okay? We have some bars from one of the
supplement companies that we have in our break room here that uses erythritol as its sweetener. So
it has a very low glycemic index. So it's very good for diabetic patients, but still eating
erythritol all the time, a sugar alcohol all the time and thinking that you're not, you know,
that you're doing good for your body is not really a truism. Is it okay to eat one of those a couple
times a week? Yeah, it's not going to be any problem. But if you're eating a couple of day thinking you're not
raising your glucose levels, well you really aren't raising your glucose levels, but it is hard for your
body to break down the sugar alcohol. So it's not something that's supposed to be, but so when we say
limited, you have to cut a use of common sense there. So common sense is based upon information. So
that's what I want to do here. Can I use natural sweeters like raw honey and pure maple syrup on a
daily basis? Well, if your diet that we put you on was a more ketogenic-like diet where we took you off
of a lot of carbs where we're limiting your grains, then you have to strongly limit these natural
sweeters. And let's leave stevey out of here, but let's talk about raw honey, pure maple syrup,
monk fruit and coconut palm sugar. These will still break down to glucose. Stevey will not break down
to glucose. So these four will still break down to glucose, so we want to limit that. So what does
that word limited mean? Well, if you're on a more ketogenic diet, so for persons on a true ketogenic
diet, you're not eating any of those. If you're on a keto-like diet, which we put most our patients on,
if you had those once a week, I'd say that would be acceptable. If you're not on that and you're on a
and you're on a mixed diet where you're decreasing some of the proteins and we have you on everybody's
off of sugar, but we're not limiting your other complex carbs. If you had this a couple times a
week, that would be fine. So if you decided to make some some cookies out of almond flour and coconut
palm sugar, could you have a couple little cookies? Sure. Could you eat the whole batch of cookies?
No. So I can't, I'm not here to give you how many cookies you could eat or how many grams of this
that you want to stick to, but you have to use some common sense. If you eat too much of any of
these things on an instability, you're going to raise your glucose levels and you're just feeding
your cancer. So part of this has to do with just, okay, is this, we could eat some raw honey, but
that doesn't mean we're going to substitute it. We're not, we're going to just make all our own
cookies now out of flowers that are carbohydrates and honey that is a simple carbohydrate and think
that we're not raising our blood sugar. Now what are the things that you can do because everybody's
body is different than how you respond to these things is you could get yourself a glucometer.
A glucometer, if you don't know what that is, is a little teeny device that you could buy a
target that has little, little strips in it that you can prick your finger and test your blood
sugar. So you can wake up in the morning and test your blood sugar. Too many of you, I'm told to do
this and you let's say at a fasting 12-hour state, your blood sugar is 85. That's really good. So it's
85 and then you eat breakfast and it bounces up to 170. So if you ate breakfast in your, in 20 minutes
after breakfast, your blood sugar would up to 170. It's a pretty good chance that you had way too many
carbohydrates in your breakfast. So did you eat waffles with syrup on it? Well, it was pure maple syrup.
Well, I know, but it was three tablespoons of pure maple syrup on the waffles. That's all carbohydrates.
It just spiked your blood sugar. That's not good. So two hours after eating 80 meal, your blood sugar
should drop back down to normal. So it's, let's say you ate it eight o'clock and it's 11 o'clock and
you test your blood sugar three hours after you eat and your blood sugar is still over 100. You're
probably spiking your glucose to high. So that's another way that you could test your old, you know, I
is my glucose level is my carbohydrate level exceeding really my body's ability to bring it back
under control because all these things, this is why we say limited because we can't give you
strict data because your body may be different. So it has to do with your pancreas ability to produce
insulin and then your cell membranes ability to receive the insulin to get the glucose out of the
bloodstream. So if you get your glucose back in normal ranges, meeting a perfect normal range would
be 75 to 90. That would be a perfect normal fasting glucose range 75 to 90 if you're not in a
ketogenic state. Then you two hours post-friend two hours post-eating, your glucose is down back to 89.
You're doing great. So you did a good job with being able to regulate that glucose back down.
If you want more help on this, then give our office a call and we can walk through your situation
directly. You have to remember with any glucose, so any food that you're eating. So food that's
breaking down the glucose, remember glucose is the sugar. So all your carbohydrates are going to
break down to glucose. Better your proteins are going to break down to glucose. It goes through a
process here that is in this arrow here called glycolysis. It's a whole bunch of steps in here.
And one of the purposes of glycolysis, it gives off energy, it gives off two ATPs. And that the
endpoint of glycolysis is this chemical called pyruvate. Now pyruvate is very important. It's the
endpoint of glycolysis. And then pyruvate is supposed to convert through this enzyme called
the PDH enzyme. This is the gene that makes that enzyme into this very important chemical called
acetyl coenzyme. Acetyl coenzyme is the entry point for the cram cycle. Why do I need to know all
this stuff? Because this is how your body makes energy. You take in food. You break it down into glucose.
It breaks down into pyruvate makes two energy molecules. It converts through this gene. That's why
when we look at your genetics, we look at that gene and we look at the HIF1 gene because these
genes are so important in breaking down pyruvate to acetyl coenzyme. Because acetyl coenzyme
sends it into the cram cycle. And this is where you really kick out energy. This takes place in
the mitochondria of the cell here. So the mitochondria of the cell, this is what's taking place.
In cancer patients, not all cancer patients, but many cancer patients. So when we test you and you
test high on pyruvate with kinesiology, or we look at your genetics and you have defects in your
PDH gene and your HIF genes, then you're going to be more apt to not be able to convert pyruvate
to acetyl coenzyme. Well, what's the big deal about that? Well, it is a big deal because you will
convert pyruvate to lactic acid. And that's what feeds cancer. It also can cause diabetes and liver
problems. But it's a made food source of cancer right there, lactate, lactic acid. Pyruvate or
pyruvate acid will convert to lactate with defects in the PDH gene and defects in the HIF gene.
And when you have excess glucose coming through glycolysis and it's unable to make this conversion,
this conversion takes some time. Matter of fact, if you really want to get technical about this,
when you are first starting to get in shape, oh, I think I need to get in shape. Well, what is the
last time you exercise Dr. Cutters? Well, it was a high school. Okay. So this is going to be a process
of getting in shape. Maybe we better start running. Oh, no, no, no. I used to run cross-cutting
high school. So I'm going to start running right away. So I go by myself, so running to choose,
and I'm going to start running and I get about a block before I'm ready to throw out and pass out.
But I push through it because I remember my days at high school that I was really a good
runner and I don't want to look silly to the people who are sitting out in their garage watching me
run by their driveway. So I keep pushing out, holding back my stomach and I push out and I run
three blocks before I'm ready to cut out and I can't figure out why I am so sore the next day.
You know where that sortus comes from? The sortus comes from, when you use your muscles that you
haven't used like that for a long time, your muscles need energy. So in order for your muscles to
continue to contract in the act of a workout, it's a calling for energy. Where do you get energy?
You get energy through glycolysis, kick it out, ATP, and then converting pyruvate into a
cedal coenzyme, go into the crab cycle, and kick it out a whole bunch of ATP. So that's energy.
So your muscles are calling for that process to take place. It's sucking glucose from your blood.
That's what we want, right? That would be really good. It's converting it to pyruvate. And then this
process through the PDH gene is time restricted. So this process takes time. So the conversion from
pyruvate to a cedal coenzyme takes time. And the less you use this pathway, the slower it is. So I
haven't really used this pathway very extensively since high school in my muscles. So this is not
converting to a cedal coenzyme. And it will remain in my muscles as pyruvate.
The problem is, is pyruvate or pyruvic acid is poisonous. And if you have excess pyruvate,
you die. So your body has this ingenious way to protect you. It converts pyruvate
through the LDH gene to lactate. So pyruvate converts to lactic acid. And the purpose is lactic acid
makes you sore. So muscle fatigue, muscle paid post workout is because of excess lactic acid in the muscles.
Because I'm not very good shape. This pathway here hasn't been stimulated very much in my muscles.
Now the more I work out, so tomorrow I'm going to work out and I'm going to be more reasonable. And I'm
just going to walk and then jog a block and then walk a couple more blocks. And the next day I'm going
to walk and jog a block and walk a couple more blocks. The next day I'm going to walk and jog two blocks.
And I'm going to keep this up. And over the course of the next four months, I'm able to convert
glucose to pyruvate and pyruvate to acetylcoidzyme more efficiently. So the more efficient
I my muscles become at converting pyruvate to acetylcoidzyme is called giddyed shape.
So be giddyed shape. So would you say are you a good shape? Yeah, I read a 5K and my time is getting better.
Now I could do it in 32 minutes or now I could do it in 21 minutes. That process of giddyed shape
literally is your ability to convert pyruvate to acetylcoidzyme more quickly.
Why is that important? Well, it is important with cancer patients because the inability to do so
will produce more fuel for a cancer. So that brings us back to the angel question. Should a cancer
patient exercise? In my statement to cross the board for a long time, it's been yes, but do it gently
and do something you enjoy because we don't want to go, oh, I think cancer patients should
exercise. So I'm going to go jump on the treadmill and do something stupid like I typically do.
Thank you to my I'm going to relive my glory days of high school when I could run a 5K at 16 minutes.
Well, that ain't ever happened again. So let's be realistic and we don't want to produce all
this lactic acid in a short period of time. Thank you that this is how I'm going to get in shape and
I got to really push it. That's not the way to do it. You want to work out very slowly so you're
not getting sore. So instead of taking four months to be able to run a 5K, it would be great if all
my cancer patients could run a 5K, that would be wonderful. They're really good at pushing this pathway.
However, if you haven't been in that position, we want to take instead of four months to get a
shape. Maybe a year and a half to get a shape. Be more patient so that we're not producing a bunch
of lactic acid. Does that make sense? I know the question was about sugar and how can we eat
natural sweeters, but I tend to think on metabolic pathways and why you would want to or not do
something. So the more sugar that you eat and that you're not exercising, you're not even pulling
this pathway. So the muscles aren't even exercising. This is why we tend to get fat when we eat
a whole bunch of sugar and it's not even producing any energy because the muscles are calling for energy.
Also, this is how we can feed cancer when we're eating things that break down to glucose, which is
any carbohydrates and things like raw honey and maple syrup are going to be higher on the glycemic
index meeting. They'll break down to sugar even more quickly. And if I'm not using that sugar to produce
energy, my cancer is going to use it to make more cancer cells. So hopefully that answered that question
even with more information that you ever wanted to know. Next question. When the liver empties
itself, during a coffee in a, where do the toxins go? Does this require 2.5 deep toxic effort?
Also, other than minerals in a lot of water for the sun, a sweating detox, does the body need extra
help there as well? Good question. So let's just make something really clear. When you do a coffee
it doesn't magically cause your liver to detoxify. It helps support detoxification
mainly by stimulating the vagal nerve, the cranial nerve,
tend in the sigmoid colon. So that is going to stimulate phase 1, phase 2, phase 2.5
detox detoxification neurologically. So does that mean you still need support for phase 2?
Point 5, like if I have PMTG defects that is decreasing my ability to make coline. So I'm not getting
bile production. Do I need support with phase 1 with maybe taking milk this? So all those things
need to be assessed with conhesiology or with some thing that we could measure that your detox
is going the way that it wants to go, that way that we want it to go. Do you need extra minerals?
If you're sweating, if you're doing a sauna, I think that's what she's alluded to to this question.
If I'm doing a sauna on a daily basis and I'm sweating out my minerals, do I need to be taking
extra minerals? Yes, possibly. It depends on how much you're sweating. It depends on whether you're
sweating other than doing the sauna. And it depends on what your diet is, too, because we really want
you to get most of your nutrients through your diet. So if your diet is, if you're using a green
product, if you're juiced, if you're eating a lot of vegetables and there are organic sources,
that you might be getting plenty of minerals. So if we're if we're really concerned about that,
it might be good to do a basic comprehensive metabolic panel. That's a blood test to make sure that
our electrolytes are not thrown off. We certainly don't want that. But you can certainly take
some minerals and again refer back to the video that I talked about that talks about good minerals
versus bad minerals and how they need to be keylated, et cetera. But taking a mineral supplement,
there's nothing wrong with doing that. You really can't hold down it. Increasing magnesium
as a as a minerals in your mineral sources as well as important that can help keep your bottles
loose as well. Next question I want to let you know that I have had continual pain
right below my left rib. I wonder if my liver was overloaded. So I've been doing two coffee
edamas a day. Don't you see a lot more hard black specks in my morning bowel movements and quite a
few liver flukes maybe after my evening edema. Glad to be getting them out. First of all,
a little bit of anatomy. Your liver really where you'll feel liver paid is going to be over the
under the right rib, typically not the left rib. Even though part of your liver is under your left
side, you're going to feel more spleen issues there. If you have paid underneath your left rib,
most likely it's colon not liver. So I wouldn't think that paid under your left rib is liver. So
that would not be my go-to. I would think that could be colon. Make sure you just, and I've told many
of you before. Sometimes it's good to put a little oil massage oil or coconut oil on your tummy
and rub your tummy. It could be good to have your partner maybe need your belly like they're making
a loaf of bread. It could be very helpful. There's a technique called bloodless surgery. There
was actually a book. I think it's out of print now written by a major doctor. Meet your Djardé. He
was one of my instructors. He was like 80s, 90s. He was my instructor back in the early 80s. But
he was just a master at that. I learned from him that technique of manipulating your viscera
from the outside in a form of what's called bloodless surgery. So that massage technique is a very old
Chinese acupuncture technique as well that you could really help get your balls moving.
I think you got 30 feet of intestines in that tummy of yours, including your stomach,
including your liver, including your spleen, and other ovaries and uterus. I mean there's a lot
of stuff going on in there. So moving that around could be very helpful in a massage like way. Black
specs in your stool. That could be so many different things there. I don't know where to go on that.
Liver flukes are very small. So is it possible that you could see liver flukes? Yes, liver flukes
are a parasite that probably the majority of people in the world have liver flukes.
And that you can see those in your stool as well. Next question. I'm getting leg cramps. So this
could have ties back to that mineral question after doing some of those. I'm getting leg cramps
during the night. Do I need more potassium in the diet? I don't think I'm behind it. I drink a lot
of water during the day. Any suggestions for this? Well, leg cramps at night, I just pulled this
little ditty off the website. If you're exercising rigorously, you could have leg cramps. Why?
Because you have lactic acid milled up in your muscles. If you have any hormonal or fluid
imbalances, electrolytic balances, this is exactly what this person is referring to. Do I need more
potassium in my diet? Dehydration could cause this. Any neurological issues could cause this as well.
But let's just talk about the most common thing. The most common thing is what this person is
alluded to in electrolyte of balance. So understand. So your electrolytes are very important
to keep in balance. That is basically your mineral content of your blood. And if they go out of
balance, what are the first symptoms? It's going to be restless legs, muscle fatigue, leg cramps,
having to wake up with Charlie Horse. That's the major side of imbalance in your electrolytes.
The misconception that people have is that they think they're dehydrated. That's why they're getting
the problem. Dehydration can cause the problem. But when we drink too much water, that could be even more
so the problem because we're flushing out our electrolytes. So we hear, oh my gosh, we need to be
drinking more water. So I'm drinking 75 ounces of water a day because that's very helpful for me.
Well, it can be, but you could be losing your electrolytes. So if you are flushing out your
electrolytes through drinking too much water, that could be the problem. Again, the only way to know
for sure is to get a blood test. But certainly before getting the blood test, I would just add some
minerals to my diet and see if that makes a difference. Now some people do better drinking less water.
I know if you're Google it, it's say, drink half your body weight in water every day. I just don't
like generalities like that because some people do much better drinking much less water than that.
And if they drink more, they flush it out. I've had people that drink too glasses of water a day and
you test their total body water on a biometric test and their total body water is 60% which is great.
And it's like you only drink too glasses of water a day and I've had people that are drinking 60
ounces of water a day and basically they're flushing out their electrolytes and they are causing
themselves to be dehydrated because it is your electrolytes that help hold your water and your tissues.
So if you're flushing out your electrolytes, you're just going to pee all the water out and you might
be drinking 60 ounces a day but then you look at your total body water out of biometric test and it's
like 45%. So you're creating a state of dehydration by drinking too much water. So add some minerals that would
be my first suggestion to your diet. You could even add some pink salt or something to your food.
That can be beneficial as a mineral source as well.
Next question. Is it normal to be tired or sleepy after surgery? Is it one's body just slowing down
to heal? It can be. So it can be normal. It's your body's a way to just slow you down so that you do
heal and that can be the possibility. You do also want to check anemia. So getting a blood test again,
we want to look at that. Too tired after surgery. That can be a side of bleed too. So it's a good idea
to just get a comprehensive blood panel by your doctor and send your results in email them to the
clinic so I can look at them because anemia can be not that uncommon post surgery. So looking at
an electrolyte balance, looking at all those mineral bands, a lot of the questions were similar
this week. It's interesting but that could be important. So I wouldn't just take it as oh,
it's a good thing I want to rest. It very well could be but it might be good to get a blood panel done
too. Okay, we're going to open it up to questions. I am going to unmute everybody and if you have any
questions, just follow me. Ed there was silence. Dr. Connors, I have a question.
Yes. I have been doing the intermittent fasting. I stopped eating about four o'clock in the afternoon.
Start up again till about eight o'clock in the morning. So you got to eat a widow of about eight hours then.
Okay. I work pretty hard and I am very fatigued. My urine is very dark as an odor to it now.
Should I back off on this a little bit? Yes. So the intermittent fasting of the time
restricted eating is very helpful but two things. If you are at your weight that we want you to be at,
then it's still good to do this but I would only do it a couple days a week.
If you are like, well, boy, I could still lose some weight. I mean, I'm happy with my weight but
it's not like I'm under weight. Then you could do it three or four or five days a week.
You do not need to do it every day. If you are more overweight and boy, I could lose of, you know,
30 pounds that you certainly could do it every day. So if you're noticing like a concentrated smell of
your urine, that's also a side of possibly not getting enough water, making sure you're drinking enough water.
You could be spilling the ammonia. I don't remember. Did I look at your genetics yet?
Yes, but we've never talked about that. Do we talk about CBS defects?
No. No. Okay. So if a person does have defects in their transalpheration pathway,
they're going to spill ammonia. Their urine is going to spill like ammonia.
Okay. I just smell it when I take some at sometimes.
Okay. So possibly even without defects, you could still have that. So you could be spilling
a little ammonia. Then you'd want to look at either if you just backed off on the TRE,
opened up your window of feeding a little bit more, increase your water input. If that changed,
and you don't have that smell that I would just forget it. If you still have that,
that I would say we need to think about reducing your sulfur foods.
I have sulfur foods, you say? Sulfur. Sulfur foods that have sulfur. And I have a list of those
on our website, under the genetic can.
Was that makes sense? Thank you. Yes. Thank you. Dr. Connors, where did you say that list was under the
it's in the it's under the genetic tab at our website.
On the page that I make everybody watch before we do your genetics.
Okay. It's one of the genetic pages where there's some links that it says,
CBS defects, managing CBS defects or something like that.
That will that would be the link to the page. It will have all the sulfur foods on there.
Thank you. I have a question. This is Christina. I just learned today that there's a
like an integrative clinic in the city not too far for me that has a hyperbaric chamber.
And I was just wondering, you know, kind of was by word of mouth and I had
done very little research on it myself as of yet. What are your thoughts about hyperbaric
chambers being helpful for cancer in general and then specific to somebody like me?
Uh, the hyperbaric chamber is got a lot of studies not just antidotal evidence, but a lot of studies
that have shown that it's be very effective for cancer because it's increasing oxygenation of
tissues. So if we actually go back to this picture right here, one of the things that pushes pyruvate
to lactic acid is anaerobic activity. So if you increase oxygenation, the thought has been
in the alternative community a lot, you're going to help push this pathway here.
So that's the studies that are coming out on it are very, very positive.
Um, the negative of hyperbaric chambers are if you have claustrophobia, you won't be able to
get at them. If you have sinus issues, I can't get at our hyperbaric chamber. I can't, it just
kills my sinuses too bad with my polyps. Um, so there are some negatives. I, we have some patients
that think they could get in there and they freak out once they get in there. The third negative is
that is you have to do it on a very regular basis. So most of you that came to our clinic and did
the two day, we did not do hyperbaric on because two days of hyperbaric is not going to change your life.
So and it's, you really have to stick to, uh, you know, daily or three times a week, um, twice a week,
we have some brain cancer patients that are doing once a week for brain cancer,
do eat any hyperbaric as beneficial for other kids or you have to stick more to a tight schedule.
So if it's three hours away to this clinic, well, it's just not real practical.
Uh, if it's a half hour to get to the clinic, well, then that could work and you could go do it
hour session, that will work just fine. So, um, you just got to look at the practicality there.
Okay. So there's nothing that, that contraindicates it as far as, go specific people. It's, it's a generally
a good thing. It's more how it, how it works into a practical schedule. That's right. Exactly.
Thank you. Uh, Dr. Connors, uh, I have been, uh, struggling with, uh,
rosacation and my nose and now it is starting to spread to my cheeks. Is there anything that I can
do for that? So rosacea, rosacea is, um, caused by H. Pylori.
So rosacea is caused by H. Pylori all the time. So H. Pylori, what's H. Pylori? H. Pylori, H.
stands for helicobacter pylori, which is a bacteria. It's a gram-negative bacteria, the same classification
with Lyme disease. H. Pylori is ubiquitous. It's everywhere. There's different species of H. Pylori that
are in our normal flora. So it's in our normal microbiota. But it's the, it's the more pathological
species that can break out of the stomach and cause problems elsewhere in the body. H. Pylori is
the cause of stomach ulcers. It's the cause of rosacea. So it is the number one cause of stomach
cancer worldwide, or due to the World Health Organization. It, uh, when it gets out of the intestines,
that's what it could cause problems. It could get in the cell and cause damage and cause
damage to the replication cycle. And that's why it could be a cause of cancer, just like anything else.
So treating the H. Pylori is essential. So call the office tomorrow and set up a time where we could
do some distance physiology because, uh, we, there's several products that work really well for H. Pylori.
And we just want to test which one would be good for you for that. I've had people with skin
breakouts. I had one woman in, uh, clinic up in Duluth that had a rash all over her arms. It looked
like she had leprosy. Tested her. It was H. Pylori, which was just a shock to me. It was, was not rosacea.
I mean, it was like, if it was rosacea, it was the worst case for rosacea ever. But it was, um, it was
literally postural breakouts, uh, put her on a product to kill the, uh, to kill the H. Pylori in a
week. It was all gone. It was crazy. So, but rosacea is, is a, is a test. It's a tough one. H. Pylori
could be a really tough one. It's, um, it's basically docking it down. You're probably never going to
get rid of it completely. Kind of like lime in the sense that you're trying to get your body to be
able to control it. So just call tomorrow and set up a time when we could do that. It will get you
better. Anything else? Well, are you guys learning stuff from these zoom calls?
Yes. Yes. Oh, good. I'm not getting too tacky or too
hatty on these. I hope not. Um, I'd like to teach, but I want to make sure you guys are like,
just closing your ears when I start talking and like, oh my gosh, here it goes again on my rear
page. But, um, so I want you guys to, I think just the more you can understand the process and how
your body works, I think you have more control over things that you, and it helps alleviate fear. So
that, that's what our, that's what my desire is in this because I think, um, I don't believe
knowledge is power, but I think knowledge helps, um, helps you overcome some, um, uh, fear for sure.
And, um, um, um, empowers you to be able to make better decisions as well. So, um, don't,
hesitate asking questions on the Facebook page as well. And, um, we'll just continue going here to
help everybody out. All right, well, we'll say goodbye for tonight. It's been about 45 minutes
and, uh, we will see you for sure next week and we'll talk to you on Facebook.
Thank you. Very good. Thank you. All right, bye-bye, everybody. Bye.